i've just spoken to josh yeah who's in
the us and the emmy's there and he said
he's missing all the cards in london i
know it's yeah
i mean yeah i've just been on facetime
to him and our hotels we've been
screaming at each other down the phone
thinking what's happening and just yeah
it's sad we can't be together for this
one but we're here tonight celebrating
how does it feel to be here with the
rest of your classmates incredible and
we've been waiting for this moment since
we wrapped in like 20
yeah last year 2020. so
crazy that this is the first time yeah
um absolutely so let's talk about
fashion you are looking absolutely
incredible tonight so tell me about this
look and how you got ready so this is by
um this looks by mimi and sort of in
collaboration with my stylist harry
lambert and um sort of wanted to
reinvent the yellow dress in a sort of
structural quite powerful way
with insane nails as well i noticed that
they'll tell me about these i can't do
anything with them
i can't use my hands um but yeah they're
there
they're long so yeah yeah i would not
want to get on the wrong side yeah
snails um so also we've seen um images
of the new cast members of the crowd
what advice do you have for them as they
kind of continue their journey oh god
just like
try and sort of
i don't know
soak in every moment because it goes so
fast because you'll be like working
really hard and surrounded by incredible
like people all the time and yeah make
the most of it because i miss it a lot
yeah it's a really really special job